new women are really really good players
I mean I guess I could give every one of
them a night and still win easily on the
terrible chest way
I don't know why I guess they get so
smart
they have never turned out a good woman
chest plate
could ever stand up against a man in the
history of chess
I plan but I don't think they're going
to play me
what do you think of women when it comes
to chess uh not too much
this has not been that kind to women I
don't believe there are any like
underlying genetic circumstances or
anything that should make men better
players but as I said the environment
has not been great towards women at the
young age there is really not that much
of a difference between boys and girls
like girls are as fascinated and as
interested in chess as voice are so
hopefully this will bark a bit of a
Revival there